kill her if you cry a timeout Atlanta  after their big lead is evaporated Lopez  and there's Trey young and done getting  into it a little bit prior to the stamp  it out the Chris Dunn and pray young I  think done sibling exception through the  elbow and pray for Jews that's all at  the timeout then up Oh she'll to the  back of the head and done and pray on  are going to get technical to it I guess  that's what it was big did you see that  the other one it's the three and that's  for Chicago to take a timeout a young  intern who stared at him looks back and  so whoa I got a tentacle for that and on  a second technical just one for taunting  gray has been ejected  unfortunately that's a League rule and  it's not much you can do about that